[PBS music]
And when you think about fictional realities
where different universes of discourses meet,
like the DC/Marvel crossovers,
you're actually engaging in some pretty serious ontological ponderings.
[laughs]
Hank: That was the nerdiest thing I've ever said.
[all laugh]
Off camera: And you have said some nerdy things!
Hank: That was like, top--top of the list.
[Theme Music]
Hank: Oh, Abby's the little artwork.
Nick: Corgis are kind of artwork,
Nick: Corgis are kind of artwork, but then again, bred...
Hank: ...so cute...
Off camera: It's a process.
Hank: "Bred," with no 'A'.
We are not mere objects that exist to be used by others.
We our...are our, we're our own ends...
But this means we can choose to develop stronger levels of control over many of our actions,
which is what we do when we get to work a break bad habit or ingrain a good one!
Some people lie more than they tell the truth.
Off camera: Those people... suck.
Like Sandy!
*accusingly* Sandy!
*laughing*
*singing* Wittgensteeein!
We're naturally built -
*fart noise*
And you must - *mlaaagh*
Maybe your desire to not care what other think - *waaargh*
Try to interpret whatever your interloc...interlocu - *blargh*
There are a whole lot of things that most of us think are totally fine,
but are actually expressly forbitten, buh-bitten
They're not just for cartoon cowboys!
*in a southern accent* Dem's fightin' words.
A brain scan revealed a large tumor in his orbito frontal -
orbito frontal cortex
orbito-front, orbito frontal cortex
orbito frontal cortex, 'kay.
They contained subjects and verbs and are glamma - glammatically legit.
But remember, if you really think that beauty is in the bo - ugh, bye of the beholder.
There are other kinds of,
there are other kinds of unintentional, ling -
There are other kinds of unintentional lingui - unintentional linguistic
The tragedy for Sartre, is that he was an atheist,
so he believed there was an emptiness that can never -
This wasn't... *arghhh*
This is a good-
Patricia Church -
- hand
Patricia Chu -
Patricia Shurshland -
and yet they consider other rules from the Old Testament to be like the Ten Command -
like the Ten Commandments
*singing* to be still binding
like the words that are coming out of your mouse-th
mouse?
No.
*singing 'Ho! Ho! Ho! To the Bottle I Go'* Sweet is the sound of the pouring rain and the sh-rain that falls from the hill to plain
better than... something. I dunno
or something that - *whoogh*
For example, the prohibition that says 'do not kill'
is a prohibition
and *whosnosumim* the other factors
Really weign- reigned it in there at the end, it's great.
Or some historical facts about the workst- *weird sound*
This is *brrr*
ah-boo boo boop
The mythical lost island that our old monk friend 'Gaun-ee-lo' said could be the-
*pained whining*
*laughing in the background*
Some beings are able to do this on their own
but, since we need to coordinate matters with a partner, God kindly instilled us with a sex drive
and made the *prrahcess* feel good
to make sure that we noo- to make sure that we dooo-it.
Thanks, God!
or that a speech act can cause nations-chr- to chrchchrr
and takes offench-
Offench?
Off camera: Offench!
[yawn]
Nick: Good take.
and that's a violation of Kant's setic-
seticah-
segli-
sah-
sedizah- I died.
Everything fell apart.
But they also think that there's something different about some human actions--
that some of the actions we take really are free.
Please, please be true.
Nicole: Just a little--
just a little bit.
each of us as- has- has a box
and Kant phrased it this way:
Act only according to that maxim which you can at the same time with whaatt--
--with that should be a universal law without contradiction.
Nick: with whaatt
*sounding very much like a duck* with whaatt
If a skunk walks through paint and leaves footprint on- footprints
He was lookin' pretty smart.
the ones that some people would include in a groooup
*emphasizing wrong syllables* but oth-ers would ex-clude.
God.
He's up there.
On the second floor.
[hauntingly] Of the univeerrrse...
or was it Ne-
-either?
Elvira's impulse is to lie and say that Tony isn't there
in order to protect him from this word-be murderer
word be?
Early 20th century German philosopher, Gottlob Frege
helped pruh-perabara-
that an artist must want to evoke some valuable emo-
*weird voice* vhaluable emootion in the auudience
We talked about hypothetical and categorical imperatives
the universi- ilisabil-
we studied the basic goods
and the way that instinct bynd-reason becomes together and shrorns the natural law
Nick: Maybe again.
Like if you're in your sister's room, having an argument, and she says, "There's the door,"
you can assume that she's not just randomly naming house parts
[laughing]
[laughing in the background]
I think that's the first time that's ever happened to me.
[laughing]
I knew it was coming too.
Nick: That's a good joke though, I can see a person in the middle of that argument who actually thinks that.
Yeah--
There's the door.
Well, there's the phone!
*laughing in the background*
There's the wall!
Okay.